[Music]
good evening welcome to another seminar
about long term thinking sponsored by
the long now foundation my name is
Stuart brand Phil tetlock has
anticipated something long now has
wanted to do by about a hundred years we
have a site called long baths org where
people register predictions right out in
public and people vote on them and they
some people bet money against them and
it's all very conspicuous and the idea
is to develop an idea over a hundred
years or so as to who's actually good at
predicting and who's quite bad and what
kinds of predictions hold up
and are worth spent spending your time
paying attention to and what kinds are
our worthless well philatelic jumped all
that by just going ahead and doing the
research on existing predictions by
experts and finding out what sifted out
from that and he's got I think one of
the fundamental ideas about long-term
thinking especially as it applies to
taking responsibility for what might
happen soon in the future please welcome
Philip tetlock thank you very much
Stuart my topic today is good political
judgment and it is a sign of the power
of politics to fog our thinking that
there is vastly more controversy
surrounding the concept of good
political judgment than there is
surrounding the concepts of say good
medical judgment or good engineering
judgment a good financial judgment the
vast majority of intelligent people feel
that there are reasonably solid
benchmarks gold standards as it were for
assessing good medical judgment patients
either do well or they do poorly you can
die bridges either stand or they fall
your portfolio either grows
dwindle by contrast good judgment ills
to most people hopelessly subjective you
really don't expect Nancy Pelosi and
George W Bush to agree and you certainly
expect in the international scene to
observe dramatic differences and how the
Iranian leadership looks at good
judgment or how Osama bin Laden views it
or Kim jong-il or Vladimir Putin so my
first task in this talk is to persuade
you that the concept of good political
judgment is not hopelessly subjective
that it is possible to construct some
reasonably objective benchmarks
I call them trans ideological benchmarks
benchmarks that experts from a wide
range of ideological and theoretical
orientations can at least grudgingly
accept and it's possible to learn a lot
from applying these benchmarks for the
purpose of assessing the judgmental
accuracy of political experts there are
two big categories of benchmarks of good
judgment that we use there are knowledge
indicators and meta knowledge indicators
so we're interested both and whether
experts get it right or wrong and we're
also interested in the degree to which
experts assign realistic subjective
probabilities to their predictions so
the degree to which experts know
something about what they know and don't
know so you do you know what you do and
do not know and I'm going to argue that
there's really only one way to find out
and that is to get in the habit of
keeping score on one's own judgmental
accuracy and it requires doing something
rather cognitively unnatural I think and
I'm speaking now as a psychologist
because my Disciplinary background is
that of a psychologist it's not an
altogether natural mental act to screw
when zone mental processes that way now
give you a quick example of what what
it's like to scrutinize one's mental
processes and I'm going to use some
non-political examples initially but
we'll slip quickly into political ones
this is a subjective probability scale
where people have a dicot
choice there are only two possible
answers so a 50% probability represents
of course maximum uncertainty coin toss
uncertainty 100% probability represents
complete confidence that you're right
and one of the research that I'm doing I
started doing in 1980s and I was then
pretty much exclusively an experimental
psychologist there was a large body of
work in experimental psychology already
on confidence and confidence calibration
measuring how realistically people could
judge states of knowledge and these
involve constructing rather elaborate
tests and exercises in which people were
asked questions like this about isotopes
or the next question France being larger
in area than Spain and we're interested
both in the accuracy of your answer and
we're interested in the accuracy of your
subjective probability assessment and
you might ask well how would you assess
the accuracy of subjective probabilities
you know we and and I'll answer that
there there are two fundamental ways to
do that one is called calibration it's
the ability to assign subjective
probabilities to outcomes that
correspond to their objective
probabilities now to do that you need to
get people to take rather long and
elaborate tests need to get them to make
a lot of predictions that one of the
things I was successful in doing was in
getting some very thoughtful people to
sit down make a lot of different
predictions now you're welcome
if when you say there's a 70% chance of
something happening the things that you
assign that 70% likelihood to occur
about 70% of the time and you're well
can you say a hundred percent
probability the thing always happens you
say 50% it only happens 50% so there's a
rough correspondence between subjective
and objective probabilities and those of
you who have some statistical background
will know that this is a somewhat noisy
measurement process so you need to make
the law of large numbers work for you
you need to get a lot of predictions to
make this to make to it to make the
results reasonably reliable and in fact
in the research I'm going to be talking
about it's based most most of the
analyses
based on approximately 28,000
predictions over a roughly 15 year
period so calibration is one aspect of
the accuracy of subjective probability
judgments discrimination is the other
key aspect I'm going to talk about today
and that's your ability to assign
sharply higher probabilities to things
that happen and to things that don't
happen now your perfect calibration
score is going to look like zero because
there's there's no gap between
subjective and objective probabilities
your perfect discrimination score is
going to look like a hundred percent so
here's an example of a graph in which on
the x-axis you've got subjective
probability judgments on the Y this you
have object of frequencies and this is
an example of someone who never is an
expert who you might characterize as
rather cowardly this is an expert who
never offers a subjective probability
lower than point four or never offers a
subjective probability higher than 0.6
so the best to get out of this character
is there minor shades of maybe
nonetheless this character SCO's score
as well on calibration because when the
the the when the individual assigns a
probability of 40% things happen about
40% of the time when the person who
signed the probability of 60% things
happen 60 percent of the time so if your
data point is on the diagonal here you
are very well calibrated you're not very
discriminating though this would be an
example of good count very good
calibration and much better
discrimination because now the experts
using a much wider range of the
probability scale from point 1 all the
way to point nine and the next one is
what we call the god profile this is
this is essentially omniscience this is
what happened when you assign a
probability of zero things never happen
when you assign a probability of one
things always happen and since you're
omniscient and a perfectly deterministic
universe that is is the way it is so
this is this is pretty formidable and I
don't think I'll be surprising anybody
when I tell you that no human being
looks like that ok this is just some
technical stuff I'm probability scoring
which I can come back to if you're
interested I'm going to just say a few
words about
how I actually came to be doing this
when you do a longitudinal study of
forecasting accuracy of the sort that
I've been doing it the project starts to
feel as long as your entire life I
started doing this back in 1984 so i i'm
i'm 52 almost 53 years old now and i
just gotten 10 year in 1984 at berkeley
and i I found myself on a committee it
was a committee that the National
Research Council committed created to
look at the dynamics of american-soviet
relations and I don't know how many of
you remember 1983 early 1984 the bullet
anatomic scientists had pushed its clock
closer to midnight that I think any
other but at any other juncture then I
think the Cuban Missile Crisis Kelo
seven had just been downed and there was
a lot of talk about the growing growing
tension in the relationship between the
United States and the Soviet Union and
there were a lot of foundations that
were interested in funneling money into
into research in this area and this
committee existed for that reason now
the interesting thing about the
situation was that you may judge
Jonathan Schell wrote a book the fate of
the earth in which he characterized
Ronald Reagan as a demented bus driver
careening down a mountain road with
sharp curves and a lot of people who are
liberals thought that the Ronald Reagan
was indeed bringing us pretty close to
the apocalypse so they're based there
basically and and and a lot of people
who are conservative thought well
Reagan's doing the right thing but the
most we can realistically hope in this
situation is to contain the Soviet Union
and the Soviet Union will retreat into
Neil Stalinist mode and that will be
that Stewart was actually sharing an
interesting story about Peter Schwartz
and Robert Gates and I actually had some
similar I have a similar kind of story I
can share with you later the dominant
view he was a senior Soviet analyst in
the mid 1980s or the dominant view was
that not nothing very good was going to
happen there were a couple of people a
couple of outliers who thought that
dramatic liberalisation under a
Gorbachev like figure could be possible
but it was by and large certainly it was
certainly not the dominant
dominant prediction so the National
Research Council is supposed to be a
nonpartisan value-neutral scientific
activity and they very carefully
doot-doot they do their due diligence
and they can't can't they had they bring
Richard pipes in and they bring Marshall
Solman and they bet the whole political
spectrum was represented in that context
and then along comes Gorbachev and it
was my first encounter with what I call
an outcome irrelevant learning situation
this is a situation in which no matter
how different the ex-ante expectations
of the experts war everyone is in a
position after the fact to explain what
happens so it really didn't matter in
some sense the the Liberals could argue
well no Reagan didn't didn't create a
nuclear war know what Reagan wasted a
lot of money and unnecessary defense
spending and the Soviet Union would have
evolved in this direction anyway
although of course very few people were
predicting that ex ante and the
Conservatives of course were eager to
claim credit now that Ronald Reagan had
won the Cold War even though they had
been on record beforehand saying that
Gorbachev was really a neo Stalinist in
disguise and it was just a pair of the
breathing spell bid Robert Gates for
example was identified with that with
that point of view until quite late
actually in the Gorbachev period but it
was an outcome irrelevant learning
situation and it convinced me that there
really would be some great value added
if someone tried systematically to keep
score on political experts and that was
what I proceeded to do I just got in
tenure so I didn't have to worry about
the gestation period of the project and
I'm move move move forward now there's a
very interesting similarity I think III
not only of course I've studied the
predictions about Soviet Union quite a
while ago I've also monitored some of
the more recent predictions about the
war in Iraq and there are some striking
similarities in the conceptual structure
of the arguments that unfold that are I
think I don't think I've been adequately
commented on it's a little bit
complicated but it's worth thinking
about because it illustrates I think it
gets to the core it gets to the core
answer as to why the concept of good
political judgment is so profoundly
controversial or as my my former
colleague Danny Kahneman
what is it about politics that makes
people so dumb there are this is a
standard two-by-two table here and the
rows are defined by ideological
perspectives the top row represents a
view of Reagan or George W Bush is
essentially a good strong visionary
leader the bottom row represents a view
of Reagan or Bush is essentially a
dogmatic stubborn and somewhat off-track
kind of leader the good historical
trajectory of the part of the policy the
United States is pursuing at the moment
and the bad historical trajectory is of
things break against American policy so
in the top square in in the in the top
left you have direct vindication so
insofar as the Cold War ended roughly as
the non American terms conserved as
quick to claim that forceful policies
work now insofar as the Cold War had not
ended on unfavorable terms for the for
the United States if in fact you wound
up with the kind of situation you wound
up in Iraq you would have observed you
would observe a series of a belief
system defenses you would observe them
saying and you'll probably recognize
some of these arguments in the context
of the Iraq debate from neoconservatives
recognized just off on timing you have
to stay the course you have to be
patient or the downward counter fence
you think this is bad
you should see what would have happened
if we hadn't so you said that's the
downward counterfactual that the war
there's a hole it's a horrible situation
we're in but it would have been even
worse but we made the right mistake
defend it would there weren't there
weren't weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq but it was prudent to set a very
low threshold for moving in because that
was because making the other mistake the
mistake of not invading when there were
weapons of mass destruction would have
been far worse Robert Gates of course
invoked that argument with respect to
Gorbachev in commenting on why he was
very slow to recognize that Gorbachev
was a genuine liberalize er he
essentially said well it was we were
making the right mistake it was prudent
to overestimate rather there's more
prudent to overestimate the Soviets than
to underestimate overestimate their
capacity overestimate their
maliciousness and finally you would
about historical trajectory is just
further support for the ascent an
essentialist view of the historical
adversary so what you see is no matter
if the Cold War had ended in a none for
a gun policies had been associated with
nasty outcomes they probably almost
certainly would have invoked
counterfactual defenses of the sort that
you see in the context of Iraq
conversely I you have a belief system
dilemma for for liberals and many
liberals were in an awkward position
explaining why the Cold War ended
despite the fact that they are
predicting that Reagan's legacy would be
would would be a bad one so they could
invoke the not worth the price defense
they could invoke the other the upward
counterfactual things could have been
just as good or better even if we hadn't
spent all this money and they can invoke
their version of the we made the right
mistake defense so what what you have is
an interesting kind of intellectual
stalemate in which because there are no
control groups in history because nobody
knows how history would have unfolded if
it hadn't been President Reagan if it'd
been a two-term Carter presidency with a
two-term Mondale follow-up who in the
audience really knows whether the Cold
War would have ended in roughly the same
way it's um it's simply not something
available for human empirical knowledge
and for that matter nobody can really
say for sure what would have happened in
the world in which we hadn't gone into
Iraq it's just that the world that we're
in seems so bad that it's hard to
imagine an alternative world that would
be worse but it's not impossible
certainly not impossible right
so it was this experience with the with
outcome irrelevant learning situations
in the 1980s that led me to the view
that partisans across the opinion
spectrum are vulnerable to occasional
bouts of ideologically induced insanity
and it is crucial there's a great public
need for developing more like epistemic
or knowledge standards for judging
judgment and having standards for
judging judgment that somehow transcend
transcend ideological boundaries but my
effort to develop the standards was
described in great didactic detail in
the book
but the key idea is to work out ground
rules for keeping score that advocates
of competing points of view can agree in
advance are fair and therefore they find
it awkward to denounce those standards
after the fact when they're in an
awkward position so we did this project
over a long period of time an 18 year
project we had 284 experts in
international affairs and they were
assigning predictions roughly about a
hundred each expert on average coming
out to about 28,000 virtually all of
them had some postgraduate training
roughly 12 years of work experience and
they included a mixture of academics
journalists some intelligence analysts
and people in various think tanks there
were certain key requirements for
developing good questions you need to
specify the outcome so clearly that they
passed the clairvoyants test so if
Stuart were a true clairvoyant I could
hand my predictions to him and Stuart
could tell you whether the predictions
were right or wrong without the need to
come back to me and say oh that lock
what exactly did you mean by a Polish
Peron or what did you mean by a backlash
in South Africa or what did the kinds of
it the types of vague verbiage you often
get from experts once you've identified
the possible futures and in sufficiently
clearly the past the clairvoyants test
and you get experts to play subjective
probabilities on each set and a lot of
our questions have this kind of a format
so central government debt in country X
is going to either hold between 35 and
40 percent of GDP it's going to fall
below or rise above that range right I
mean this is one of the more farsighted
questions we asked although this
question you might note was not all that
far sighted because it never really
occurred to us that the Communist Party
would collapse so the closest we came to
anticipating the future here was as good
its control would weaken but it's an
illustration of what we're what we're
getting at so we asked a lot of
questions different nation states plus
some questions bearing on the
EU NATO World Trade Organisation lots of
different things economic performance
growth inflation unemployment policy
priorities defense spending leadership
changes border conflicts entry exits
from international agreements and we had
different types of forecasting horizons
for different variables so we had
shorter ranges for the faster-moving
variables like stock markets and we had
slower we had very long time or raising
prices for things that move very slowly
like border changes for example so some
of our predictions haven't even come due
yet having to do with border changes
okay among other things we discover this
we discovered that contrary to what most
political powers as partisans would have
expected namely that their side would
win we find that traditional divisions
of political opinion don't matter all
that much
it didn't matter all that much it mean
in terms of academia we had lots of
different theoretical contrasts that
might sound a little alien made realist
versus institutionalists or
constructivists and we had we had
optimist versus pessimist boom stirs
versus doom stirs didn't make much of a
difference
we had liberals versus conservatives it
didn't make all that much of a
difference the content of what people
thought was not a very good predictor of
how accurate they were what was a good
predictor of how accurate they were it
was how they thought at least if you're
if you're what you're interested in is
aggregate accuracy
what matters is principally how you
think and this brings us to the point
about boxes and hedgehogs and I was
actually stunned by the consistency of
the result that experts whom we
classified as foxes and I can explain
how we classified actually experts into
these categories in a moment but experts
who when we classified as foxes beat
hedgehogs and it was an advantage we
could not make a go out it was very hard
to make it disappear statistically so we
tweaked it in all sorts of different
ways to see if it was an artefact of
chance in some way or an artifact of
different error avoidance priorities all
sorts of different control mechanisms
and the Fox advantage really does how it
does prove to be quite robust but who
are these foxes and hedgehogs well
there's an essay by Isaiah Berlin that
came out about 45 years ago in which he
as on a fragment of Greek poetry from
2500 years ago by the Greek warrior poet
arkla 'kiss which is roughly translated
as the Fox knows many things but the
Hedgehog knows one big thing and he
defines the ideal type Hedgehog as an
expert or a professional or a thinker
who relates everything to a single
central vision in terms of which all
that they say has significance so you
could be a Marxist Hedgehog or you could
be a libertarian Hedgehog you could be a
boom stir Hedgehog or you could be a
doom stir Malthusian Hedgehog you could
be a realist Hedgehog you could be an
idealist Hedgehog the important thing is
that you approach history you approach
current events in a deductive frame of
mind you have certain first principles
and you try as hard as you can to absorb
as many different facts into the
framework of those first principles now
that might sound like rigidity but if
you think about it for a minute from a
philosophy of science point of view it
also is parsimony that is what
scientists are supposed to do they're
supposed to explain as much as possible
with as little as possible so we'll come
back to that that value tension in a
moment the ideal type fox's berlin
defined this way he said they pursue
many ends often unrelated and even
contradictory they entertain ideas that
are centrifugal rather than centripetal
without seeking to fit them into or
exclude them from anyone all embracing
inner vision those are the foxes so
foxes and hedgehogs foxes are skeptical
of big theories you're not going to find
very many foxes who are true believers
and interestingly the foxes who did the
best of my forecasting exercises were
the least enthusiastic about
participating and they are the most
different about their ability to
forecast because they really do see
history as in substantial measure is
quite as quite unpredictable
whereas the hedgehogs were more
enthusiastic about it they tended to be
more enthusiastic about extending their
favourite theories into new domains and
they tend to be more confident in their
ability to
predict now this is some some data which
I'll just go over very quickly if you're
on the pert the perfect diagonal the
straight line here represents perfect
calibration so the whereas the the curvy
lines represent actual groups of human
beings making thousands of predictions
and these are aggregations of that and
the key thing to note here is that one
of the lines strays further from the
perfect diagonal and all the other lines
so the line that strays furthest is the
line in which hedgehogs are making
long-term predictions within the domains
of their expertise whereas the line
that's closest to the perfect diagonal
is foxes making short-term predictions
within the domain of their expertise now
there's an argument that that started to
unfold about whether the Fox whether the
foxes were doing better than the
hedgehogs not because they're more
perceptually accurate but rather because
the foxes are excuse the pun foxes were
chickens the foxes were on unwilling to
say anything much more than maybe so the
foxes were clinging around the
subjective probability point 0.5 all
right so one way to test that if that
were true then the foxes should not be
as discriminating as the hedgehogs the
hedgehogs should may lose on calibration
but they should win on discrimination so
in this little graph here what we do is
we plot both calibration better
calibration on the x axis better
discrimination on the y axis and as you
move toward the upper right you move
toward better and better performance and
what you see is that the Fox
FST FLT represent foxes making
short-term and long-term predictions and
you can see that they're doing better
than hedgehogs making short-term and
long-term predictions HST and H LT and
they're better on both calibration and
discrimination so I think that rules out
the foxes were just chickens hypothesis
there is however one slightly disturbing
result at least from the standpoint of
those who want to argue that the foxes
are particularly brilliant and that is
when you compare the Fox accuracy of Fox
predictions to the accuracy of
predictions that you could have
generated by using very simple
statistical algorithms like predict No
change or predict the most recent rate
of change when you use that as your
benchmark of comparison I that's whether
that's what we're calling MC mindless
competition and you can see the mindless
competition is pretty close to the foxes
and so it's it's not exactly a great
vindication of human intuitive judgment
[Music]
now you might ask what do hedgehogs do
well and the answer is they assign
higher probabilities to big changes that
do materialize so if you want to know
who is really out front really out front
in predicting some of the bigger changes
that have occurred over the last twenty
years and it there were a couple of
hedgehogs actually out front with
respect to the Soviet Union and the
decline of the Soviet Union we called
them ethnic nationalist fundamentalists
these were people who argued that the
Soviet Union was essentially a prison
house of nations
it was inherently unstable and it was
going to fall apart now bear in mind
these people had been predicting the
Soviet Union would fall apart back in
1960s in the 1970s as well you know it's
like the broken clock is it is
eventually right but then but but they
were right about this they they're right
but they're right because at a high
prices that you're paying a high price
and false positive predictions so when
you rely on the hedgehogs the Hedgehog
predictors you're gonna get a lot of
false positives so the price of being it
of successfully predicting the
disintegration of Yugoslavia or the
disintegration of the Soviet Union is
that you're also predicting the
disintegration of Canada of India of
Kazakhstan of Indonesia of Nigeria of
South Africa it's a long list and that
that of course helps to explain what the
head jobs aren't doing as well they're
assigning high probabilities to low
frequency events which makes them much
more interesting than the foxes but it
also makes them substantially more
incorrect now a friend of mine Esav
Talib who whom I suspect will probably
be here at some point as just finished
writing a book on black swans in which
he talks about the radical
unpredictability of the world
if you want to know the the advantage of
being a hedgehog it's that there was
always that there's usually at least a
few of them who were out front in
predicting outlandish outcomes so actual
black swans that the hedgehogs were in
the forefront of predict expecting at
least a few hedgehogs their most
hedgehogs were wrong but there are at
least a few hedgehogs who were out front
we're in the list here as collapse of
the USSR in 1991 the Yugoslavia war
Saddam's invasion of Kuwait the Rondon
genocide financial turbulence preceding
the collapse of long-term capital
management in 1998 the East Asian
currency crises and the Russian debt
default the internet bubble the 90s went
is puncturing terrorist strikes alone
owned predicting 911 but terrorists
increased incidents of terrorism but
again lots of false positives so
predictions of the great American and
then global depression of 1990s remember
Dow at 36,000 remember Nasdaq 5000
actually had Nasdaq 5000 or Dow 1500 in
Nasdaq 350 addicting a neo Stalin this
coup in Moscow that brings the return of
the Cold War and of course predicting
full-blown civil wars in places such as
South Africa Nigeria Pakistan India
China Korean Peninsula Ukraine and
Kazakhstan and even the use of nuclear
weapons in the Indian subcontinent or
the Korean Peninsula the two most
popular sites for making predictions of
that sort now I I'm gonna I think I run
out of time so I should be getting how
much more time do I have okay well I
want to leave lots of time for
questioning I but I want to say that I I
think it's it's it's tempting for me as
a psychologist who is long interested in
individual differences to treat this as
a horse race between foxes and hedgehogs
I think that's fundamentally the wrong
way of looking at this I think it makes
more sense to think about how hedgehogs
and foxes existing and kind of
interdependent intellectual ecosystems
so on the one hand you've got the
hedgehogs who are very good at seizing
on big ideas and pushing them as far as
reasonable and then often a good deal
further and on the other hand you have
the foxes almost playing the role of
intellectual scavengers they're picking
bits and pieces of big Hedgehog ideas
and they're creating eclectic mishmash
--is that on average have more
predictive power than the original ideas
had so I think this has interesting
implications for optimal intellectual
diversity in setting up teams I think
I'd also say give you a quick example of
how that would work in the context of
the Soviet Union the there were some
people Gerry Hoff I'm thinking of a
Soviet ologist for example who were out
front and predicting that Gorbachev
would be a liberalise er before a lot of
other people were but the people who are
out front in predicting that Gorbachev
would be a liberal Iser tended to be
people who saw the Soviet system as
having more internal legitimacy than it
did the people who thought that the
Gorbachev being a liberal it would be
impossible to have a liberal Iser emerge
out of the Kremlin the gene
Kirkpatrick's and Richard pipes of the
world who saw the Soviet system as
infallibly self reproducing in a
totalitarian mode those people thought
that a Gorbachev liberalisation would be
impossible because the Kremlin
leadership would recognize that if they
liberalized things would fall apart
certainly wouldn't be stupid enough to
do that
so who would be best positioned both to
predict Gorbachev liberalisation and
Soviet disintegration it wasn't the
Liberals
who thought the Soviet system had more
legitimacy than that and it wasn't the
conservatives who were ruling out the
possibility of liberalisation in the
first place it was a small group of
foxes who had successfully managed to
commit to integrate in their minds some
liberal cognitions and some some
conservative cognitions they had
integrate they were willing to accept
the liberal insight that the Soviet
leadership like most political
leadership's in human history was not
totally monolithic and there were
genuine differences of opinion within it
so they're willing to accept that but
they also tended toward the more
conservative view that the Soviet system
didn't have legitimacy and that once
lid was lifted all hell would break
loose so that's an interesting way of
looking at perhaps the situation in Iraq
you could imagine various types of Fox
cognitions there you could imagine Fox
cognitions that would would put try to
try this dissonant possibility for
example it could well be that the Bush
administration made a massive massive
mistake it certainly is the case that
the conservative we've studied who were
sympathetic to the invasion of Iraq in
the first place or have been wrong on
many many predictions over the last two
to three years but it's also the case
that nobody knows what's going to happen
in the next 20 or 30 years so Fox is
often have a way of taking of staking
out interesting contrarian positions
that both liberals and conservatives
find Dirksen and Fox position might be
that the evident might have no I
conservatives by saying that the Iraq
war was stupid on the other hand it
might annoy liberals by saying you know
that it's in it's perfectly possible in
the next ten or fifteen years the
situation in Iraq might be far better
and it would have been if Iraq had been
under the leadership of geudae Hussein
so foxes have a way of of annoying
people across the political spectrum
they have a way of annoying people who
have entrenched theoretical positions
and those are the people who in my
exercises tend to do tend to do better
they don't get everything right they get
a lot of things wrong I think we live in
an inherently probabilistic world and no
but nobody's really expecting
omniscience but it turns out that a
somewhat contrarian self-critical
cognitive style does translate into more
realistic subjective probabilities being
assigned to possible futures and if you
think that there's that good policy
depends on assigning more realistic
probabilities to possible futures or if
you're into you think that making more
money depends on assigning a realistic
subjective probabilities possible
futures that's probably a result worth
we're taking into consideration do you
have enough questions this is hot stuff
thank you I can't help wondering right
from the start you were looking at
predictors some of these predictors hold
policy positions you mentioned Robert
Emma gates at CIA does it make a
difference if people who are actually
taking responsibility for these
decisions serve foxes or hedgehogs you
know I do have to make a disclaimer in
order to get the cooperation of the
people that I got the cooperation of I
had to promise some anonymity so I can't
say I cannot confirm one way or the
other whether any particular person was
a participant in his forecasting
exercise like it's I think it's public
knowledge that Robert Gates in the mid
1980s was a senior Soviet Soviet analyst
who is very reluctant to acknowledge
that Gorbachev was a genuine liberalize
er sure enough yeah in fact the the
story and that's actually worth telling
is it relates to this whole question of
the the one big idea or the the foxy
approach to many ideas the conversation
that was had in 1980s was when my
colleague and a board member here Peter
Schwartz was at Royal Dutch Shell and
they did some scenarios of what was
going to happen in the Soviet Union and
basically just looking at the core
economics there they conclude that one
of four potential scenarios was that
Soviet Union would collapse and assign a
leading indicators we say if that
direction would be if this mid-level guy
named garbage shop started rising to the
top and indeed that was what came to
pass and this is one of the few groups
that actually predicted that while that
was still just a prediction Peters asked
to get the presentation of the senior
leadership of the CIA to spell all of
this out so it went through the four
scenarios that were being considered in
a very foxy way and one person across
the table said I'm fine with this it's a
good way to think on the other hand one
of yours
Janeiro's that one about the collapse of
the Soviet Union is should not be on the
table at all it will not happen in my
lifetime or your lifetime or your
children's lifetime those people are
there to stay
and that was Robert M gates our new
Secretary of Defense so I'm not giving
away any any of your secrets and I
mentioned that but what's interesting
and that's what I'm coming to hear is
here's a person who's gone from policy
analyst to now a position of real power
and what's your sense of how this
different frames of looking at things
learning from mistakes and stuff like
that plays out in policy makers as well
as policy advisers I think one of the
most interesting differences between
hedgehogs and foxes in our in our data
set is that hedgehogs are substantially
more willing to use the extreme end
points of the probability scale when you
say there's a probability of 1.0 of
something happening you're saying that
you cannot imagine any alternative to
that possible future when you attach a
probability of zero to something
happening you're saying take it off the
table it's not it's not it's not even
worth your consideration hedgehogs are
roughly two and a half to three times as
likely to assign zeros or ones to
possible futures and that isn't they do
indeed they're at their accuracy does
indeed suffer because when they say
things are inevitable those things have
happened only about 78% of the time and
when they say things are impossible
those things happen about 20% of the
time so you're taking a taking a big hit
it's also the case psychologically that
the mean mathematically the subjective
probability scale is is a linear
interval scale so when you move from a
probability of 0 to 0.1 that is from
mathematical point of view should be the
same as moving from probability from
point 1 to point 2 or from point 2 to
point 3 when economists do their
expected utility calculations and so
forth probabilities are treated as
interacting and in a multiplicative way
with utilities so the probability scale
has a clear mathematical
meaning in that sense for human beings
that's not the way things work in fact
one of the most one of the best
psychologists who ever studied
probability his name is Amos Tversky he
passed away 10 years ago now he was fond
of saying the human beings can really
only distinguish three levels of
probability you know not not ten or a
hundred people can only distinguish
three levels a probably think it's
things are impossible things are certain
and then there's maybe and and
everything else every everything between
impossibility and Nevitt ability is is
he thought of as being all something
mushy so when you assign a probability
of zero or one people really listen when
we've have I were to say well you know
I've changed my probability from point 6
to point 7 that doesn't have anywhere
near the impact of saying I've moved
from point nine to 1.0 or I've moved
from point 1 if gates had said well it's
only a 10% probability he's but he said
no it's zero take it off take it off the
table that is it is interesting now it
is true that Gates later would argue
that the reason he was so skeptical of
the genuineness of Soviet reform is that
[Music]
he thought that it was the prudent
mistake to be making it was the right
mistake that he sort of knew that
Gorbachev really was he seemed to be
some kind of genuine liberal he was
willing to concede that but but he
headed he just said his threshold for
saying that very high and and he of
course never reached that threshold
until after the back do we waste our
time telling hedgehogs and that are
wrong I mean with you know he's talking
heads on the television to keep
blathering away and you can show them it
seems like you show them video of them
saying is something which turned out to
be grotesquely wrong and they don't care
what's going on there what you see when
you you you come back to experts and you
say to them well you know you what you
attached you know a point-8 likelihood
to this event and and it and it didn't
happen there's this other thing that you
only attached a point one likelihood or
a point to likelihood to that happen
instead what can they say well in any
given instance is very hard to say
they're wrong I mean you if the surgeon
says there's a point nine likelihood of
your recovering and you fail to recover
the surgeon can quite legitimately say
well there's a point one likelihood of
your not recovering and we happen to
have slipped into an unlikely world
that's why it's so critical when you
measure good judgment to measure good
judgment repeatedly you need to make the
law of large numbers work for you
because you experts have the perfectly
legitimate philosophically legitimate
defense well we happen to live in an
unlikely world that defense wears thin
the more often it's invoked now experts
have a lot of other very ingenious ways
of neutralizing inconvenient facts so if
you had expected for example that Canada
would disintegrate a number of very
thoughtful people thought that Canada
was finished and and they may they may
be right maybe they are just off on
timing and but that is the defense
they'll offer they'll say well Canada
hasn't disintegrated yet it hasn't
disintegrated by 2002 but you know what
it will by 2012 I was merely off on
timing and only a pedantic
hair-splitting professor would possibly
care about their care about that or they
might say something like you know what
I'm wrong but I was almost right so
people who thought that the the
disintegration of the Soviet Union was
very unlikely possibility argued that
well you know what if that coup attempt
in August 1991 had succeeded if
Khrushchev and those other guys who were
attempting that coup against Gorbachev
in august 19 125 laps scenarios are
right it's it's interesting that experts
tend to invoke them more frequently when
they're useful for rec for rescuing
floundering forecasts here's a question
from I think it's Charles Warner or a
name that looks like that well why
didn't you include a non-expert control
group in your 18 years study to see if
the experts were any better or worse all
we did we did I in fact maybe I can go
back to that it's a great question we
actually have a number of minimalist
baselines
for comparing whoops where did I go let
me excuse me for one second here I'm I'm
we have hmm it we what we did is we we
asked a group of briefly briefed
Berkeley undergraduates in the early
1990s to make a series of predictions
about some of the countries that experts
were making predictions of it in the
1992 round to forecasting exercises and
what happened is a little bit gratifying
for the experts
there aren't many sources of
gratification here for experts but they
did indeed beat the this is a particular
kind of dilettante that they they
resoundingly be they they beat their own
students at least the date the data
point here number thirty-seven
represents the briefly briefed Berkeley
undergraduates so what that means is the
Berkeley briefly briefed Berkeley
undergraduates were worse on calibration
and worse on discrimination than even
the very worst Hedgehog's so there
actually was some superiority manifested
there that it's a very complicated
question of what of what are the right
control groups here I mean we also
included the minimal the mindless
competition the simple statistical
algorithms seeing out whether experts
could out predict simple extrapolation
algorithms and things of that sort and
that was very hard competition for
experts to be and when you ramp it up a
little bit and use more sophisticated
statistical models the Excel virtually
all the experts lose which is if there's
an interesting fact for those of you who
are interested in that debate between
actuarial versus intuitive forecasting
approaches intuitive does well well no
[Laughter]
foxy couple questions were laid here on
sort of vast activity Gary wolf where's
Gary right back here
are there prodigies of prediction
outliers whose performance is so good
that they suggest tools of approach
worth studying and another person asks
been who is the single most accurate
expert you studied and how accurate
that person mm-hmm well I can't the
second question unfortunately I can be
pretty generic and describing does
anybody really accurate as well first
thing the thing is if you reveal the
winners you're implying the losers in
some sense in some contexts good what
was the other question about well where
there are there are there outliers are
there people whose forecasting
performance is just really off the
charts and the short answer to that is
no my data are much more consistent with
the Andy Warhol 15 minutes of fame
hypothesis that everybody even the
hedgehogs have their moments in the Sun
every of everybody gets some things
right the Foxes tend on average to be
right more often but it's not that
they're spectacularly right you mean you
see that the at the the the very best
foxes are only substantive slightly
better than simple extrapolation
algorithms so the notion that there are
forecasting geniuses in my data set I I
really can't say there's much support
for that it's I hate to do you
romanticize this but it's it's a story
of a lot of human beings possible very
well-educated extremely thoughtful
extremely knowledgeable human beings
making good-faith efforts to understand
the world around them and the world is
really hard it's it's just chart it's a
highly probabilistic quirky place it's
really hard to there aren't any control
groups for drawing causal lessons
everything is hinging on counterfactual
comparisons it's very very hard for
given the information at our disposal
and given the highly politicized nature
of these debates for human beings to to
do all that well now there are
mechanisms for trying to improve things
which I think are interesting and and
we've done a little bit of work with
them but not much and the prediction
markets I think are a tool that is worth
I think pursuing seriously prediction
markets do force people to be more
fox-like pretty
markets forced people to second-guess
their own judgment because when you're
doing when you're participating in a
prediction market you're aware that
other people are second-guessing you so
it naturally puts you in a more
self-critical mindset and I think that
there is evidence that that doesn't
prove prove improve the quality of
judgment it's not it's not turning
people into visionaries I mean we're not
dealing with a Biblical prophecy here
we're dealing but we're dealing with
incremental statistical improvements
have you tried racing prediction markets
against experts well the data are pretty
clear have you had sir Wicky come here
and wisdom of the crowd we haven't yet
and there's a question asking how does
this relate to his stuff with wisdom of
the crowd it does relate in in in in
complicated ways it generally is the
case that that aggregates of experts do
better than the individual experts and
what happens here it's a little bit
complicated
the Hedgehog's make more extreme
mistakes in both directions they're over
predicting change for the worse they're
over predicting change for the better
so when you take a statistical average
of Hedgehog's those those errors tend to
cancel each other out so the average
Hedgehog prediction is much much better
than the average individual Hedgehog
there's a huge improvement from
aggregation there the Foxes also benefit
somewhat but they don't benefit nearly
as much from aggregation as the
hedgehogs do so if you're going to have
a lot of hedgehogs on your team you
really want to consider some kind of
aggregation rule and this is without any
prediction market stuff this is simple
statistical averaging now the Foxes gets
some increment but the hedgehogs get a
really big increment and I would think
that those effects would probably be
more pronounced in a prediction market
context but I don't have anything
definitive to say on that here's a
question from Robin Sloane Robin way
back there I love this kind of tracking
any plans or just ideas to bring
prediction accountability more strongly
into the public sphere maybe you could
start a website what do you think would
that have value and for example I can
imagine on this racing not only expert
opinion perhaps named expert opinion
this would all be out in public it would
be public opinions which they've
expressed you could run your prediction
algorithms I'd love to know what they
are for example it sounds like one of
them is things won't change very much
they're pretty simple okay what are the
others just in them to know well predict
the most recent rate of change okay
yeah and then there's a simple there are
a couple of simple time series
autoregressive kinds of models since
those are so good better than most
hedgehogs and and as good as many foxes
it'd be kind of fun to see those out in
public where people could just you know
look at that in context of things that
we care about and then they'll race it
against the wisdom of crowds and the
rest of it and see these things play out
where I think the suggestion here at
long Beth's is sort of about this is
that people get to watch this in
progress and in a sense participate in
it with their own voting or whatever it
might be I think that's an excellent
idea
I have a certain amount I think it's a
great idea but I'm also a little bit
pessimistic and I'll explain why I think
that you have to ask yourself what are
people consuming when they're consuming
expert judgment are they consuming truth
claims way as an analytical philosopher
would say they're interested in the
mentally in the truth of subjective
probability claims or are they consuming
interesting stories
consider for example Saudi Arabia people
have been predicting the disintegration
of the Saudi royal family and and the
Saudi regime for 20 plus years now
eventually they may well be right the
Saudi regime may well fall but imagine
you've got two different maidan imagine
you're you know producing a television
show say or you want to attract a large
audience and you have a choice between
two experts one of them is a fox who has
a much higher calibration discrimination
score and it comes on and says you know
what yes there's about a point two four
chance the saudi the saudi regime will
disintegrate it's a fairly low
probability though because in general
it's a bad bet to bet against regimes
that control powerful means of coercion
and regimes that control a large amounts
of money and they can co-opt opposition
side of regime has a lot of resources at
its disposal to stabilize the situation
but there are inherent sore
of instability versus of someone who
comes on and says you know the Saudi
regime is doomed and that says it
confidently says it emphatically with a
very high probability verging
uncertainty and then sketches an
interesting story about some young
ambitious fundamentalist Islamic
Colonels in the Saudi royal airforce or
whatever it is taking over and and the
price of oil going up one hundred and
fifty dollars a barrel and all sorts of
terrible things see if it's not it's not
really an even contest is it even though
the apocalyptic expert is almost
certainly going to do worse in my study
then the then the more restrained expert
the apocalyptic expert is just vastly
more mediagenic just vastly more
attractive to a mass audience and
they're changing it to Hedgehog news
actually
[Laughter]
that'll be fun you mentioned before we
came up here that one indicator was sort
of the the degree of charisma of the
public expert how does that play against
this well what we find essentially is
that there is an inverse relationship
between what makes people attractive as
public presenters and what makes them
accurate and he's forecasting accuracy
exercises what we're saying here here's
a very quick crude indicator the more
howevers but all those you hear in an
expert statements the more signs that an
expert is qualifying and layering and
indicating trade-offs and and and and
sources of uncertainty the more people's
lies are likely to glaze over but the
more likely the expert the experts
objective probabilities are going to
translate into something reasonably
accurate so there is a dilemma here and
it's an interest
a couple questions here that relate one
from Andrew Fitzgerald did you find your
subjects to learn from their mistakes
once they start keeping score do they
try to improve it and another question
can how to think be measured and taught
those are those are really hard in
interesting questions
experts do change their mind to some
degree in the fourth chapter of my book
I go into what happens when experts win
and lose reputational bets reputational
bet is when you assign different
likelihoods to outcomes based on my
opponents understanding and my
understanding and we see what happens
and then one side I was morose belief
change to another side and there is some
change now most of the two might expect
experts are much more likely to change
their minds and increase their
confidence in their position when they
get it right so experts increasing the
likelihood they're being right that's a
relatively easy thing the unnatural
thing is reducing their confidence in
their prior position foxes do that more
than hedgehogs that is I believe part of
the mechanism by which they're able to
achieve superior accuracy they do change
their minds in a more timely way but it
doesn't feel like dogmatism to those who
are
changing their minds it feels like
they're there that that things happen
that we're not reasonably foreseeable
and they're simply qualifying a previous
position in a reasonable way that Canada
did almost come undone for example
consider that Canada whether Canada was
going to come apart because it was an
issue in contention in the 1990s the
second secessionist referendum in Quebec
it was like almost it wasn't quite as
close as the Florida vote in 2000 but it
was fifty point one percent voting no-go
voting against secession that's well
within the margin of sampling error so
is an expert wrong for saying well it
almost happened there is a certain
amount of indeterminacy in the world and
it just happens to be the case that
experts latch onto that indeterminacy
kind of strategically and they they're
much more likely to embrace
indeterminacy when it helps them to save
their preconceptions and the Hedgehog's
are especially likely to do that so from
your background in psychology do people
ever change their thinking mode to
Hedgehog's ever become foxes to fox has
ever fall in love with one of their
theories and become hedgehogs yeah ours
this genetic well you know that's a
great question can I come through there
was a second question actually about
whether people can be trained okay I
think that's that I wanted to come to
that and but I'll turn to that other one
too that is one of the hardest not fully
resolved questions in the psychological
literature is whether training people in
calibration exercises for example is
going to generalize so if I can if we
work through a series of exercises in
which you know you were to make
judgments about whether France is bigger
than Spain or whether the moon ever
comes closer than 225 thousand miles to
the earth if you made a bunch of
judgments in in different domains would
that generalize into a superior
calibration and superior forecasting
skill going forward in other domains
would it make you a better predictor of
trends and financial markets or
political trends or what-have-you
that that issue has not really been
been resolved there certainly work in
progress on that there seems to be some
generalizability but it's there it's
hard it's hard to get to get big
generalizability effects right there
there's a certain amount of charlatans
ISM gunning around there are certainly
people who are making claims that they
can train you and they can transform you
and I would I would I would caution
about that but but there may be some
element of truth to the to the training
so back to the question is it genetic
well it's not even a dichotomy Minaya
brilliant actually talked about
hedgehogs who wish they were foxes and
foxes who thought they were hedgehogs he
talked about Tolstoy who looked like he
was both right and and and we actually
do break down this way we have a series
of questions for classifying people as
hedgehogs or foxes and it's like a
personality scale and you you can you
can slice and dice it in lots of ways
and and and doing simply an absolute
dichotomy median split kind of thing
hedgehogs and foxes it's quite
artificial I mean there there are some
people the people in the middle are are
really high groups of various sorts and
and the hybrids do behave somewhat
differently from the people at the
extremes
is there an age element by the way did
someone ever start out sort of foxy and
wind up hedge Oggy
people do change and and but I was going
to come to your point about genetics
because the Fox Hedgehog scale is very
closely related to the openness factor
in the major taxonomy of personality
called the big five and there are lots
of behavioural genetic studies that bear
on that including identical twin studies
and the like and so and yet so the
answer is there is some genetic
component to being a fox or a hedgehog
the answer is also that there's a large
socialization component to it and most
people who are reasonably intelligent
have within their repertoire doing it
either way so it's it's it's not it's
not totally fixed but it is a preferred
style that some people more much more
readily slip into than other people do
and and they don't see it as a bias well
you get people sort of breaking down
their foxie about their business but
they're a hedgehog when it comes to
religion or something like that
sure yeah
just in your pool of the experts see
we're looking at a question from Karen
Tomlinson what is the percent of the
pool who are hedgehogs versus foxes you
can define that so that's a tricky one
if you just use a median split you can
just arbitrarily say 50/50 my sense is
that a more realistic interpretation the
scale would be that you have about you
hit you have a reasonably normal
distribution with fat tails in which
you've got about 20 percent fit fairly
nicely within the Fox 20 percent within
the Hedgehog and then about 60 percent
of the population I don't think are all
that readily classifiable one way or the
other you could think of them as switch
hitters or cognitively ambidextrous
whatever you want to do I didn't want to
say they're here of question here
anonymous interesting are you a fox or a
hedgehog while he's thinking I'm a fox
you know it's when you're so immersed in
this stuff it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's hard and I I read I I ran into a
lot of experts who really balked at this
classification scheme and I have to
admit I I see one of them I sympathized
with them I sympathize with them but
it's gonna sound as though I'm favoring
my own side but I do think of myself I
like to think of myself temperamentally
as more Fox like but I can often sense
myself slipping into Hedgehog dogmatism
so what's your sense of the sort of
future of this lore I mean here's a
bunch of people and then there'll be
tens of thousands who will sample this
online who are now hip to this whole
point that you've been making you've
been studying for two decades you know
as that becomes public knowledge that
there are these two ways of thinking
about
the future and one is actually more in
aggregate accurate than the other is
there any possibility the behavior would
move in some aggregate way as a result
of that it's certainly possible but the
reactions that hedgehogs have to
empirical surprises
the reactions hedgehogs have been
relatively unexpected things occur
suggest a great reluctance to
acknowledge that one that they're that
they are wrong in any significant
respect so I'm not sure I see it it
takes very dramatic evidence to induce
belief change nights why I think I think
change does occur dramatisation ISM in
America disappeared after Pearl Harbor
there were lots of isolationist and then
suddenly it was a political perspective
it was legitimate and influential
suddenly disappears and they come back
after Iraq so dramatic events can do
that but okay hedgehogs won't change
that's their specialty how about foxes
would foxes get more kind of loud and
proud and confident and have more
audience with their howevers because of
all this well the way the system works
foxes typically make such qualified and
nuanced predictions they're not in a
very strong rhetorical position after
the fact to say oh look I claimed that I
predicted that they're there they're
there they're there were lots of people
for example prior to the invasion of
Iraq who offered very complex nuanced
analyses saying they were sympathetic to
the concerns about weapons of mass
destruction but they were very concerned
about the sectarian violence that would
arise in Iraq and very concerned about
Iran and they they offer they offered
many layers of nuance a very very few of
them offered extreme probabilities very
few said this is going to happen
they were hedging their bets they they
didn't really know what kind they knew
knew that some kind of Shiite leadership
with him would emerge in Iraq but they
didn't know the nature of that
leadership whether it simply be a mask
for sectarian violence
or whether it would be with the the Neil
wilsonian dreams of people are Charles
Krauthammer would okay be realized here
you've been Iraq's pretty good this is a
live case for all of us it counts I mean
people dying everywhere and politics in
America hanging in the balance and all
the rest of it so you've been studying
the various forms of expertise they've
been holding forth about what will play
out in Iraq and people are voting here
and elsewhere on what they think about
what will play out in Iraq and how to
get to perhaps a desired state from your
foxy point of view how would you spell
out the way things might go in Iraq over
the next say five years now you bear in
mind I'm a psychologist so I observe the
observers and I made it a strict policy
for 20 years not to make predictions of
my own okay but you've been listening to
a number of experts some of whom you
have reason to disbelieve and some of
you have reason to believe and based on
that without your judgment coming into a
play here who has persuaded you how
things might go in Iraq not who but you
know what what were the persuasive
stands from the Foxes that you've been
listening to this heart let me let me
just think for a second here that's fair
this is not the National Intelligence
Council you can actually sort of wing it
yeah no I know and III understand my
opinions are inconsequential
[Laughter]
I would I think that this is a situation
in which the regional experts have done
really well the Bush administration I
think pretty much decided to ignore most
Arabists and Middle Eastern experts when
they made this choice and you know as
you know from my data the regionalists
often get it wrong
but this is a situation where the
regionalist got it right and the reason
lists that you're listening to or saying
what now
the consequences have been horrific
going forward what did they say you know
that they really do hedge in the foxes
hedge they had the hedge a lot and and
and I I think that the the modal view
right now is that the bloodshed is going
to get significantly worse and there's a
spiral of violent violence it's going to
be very very difficult to contain and
that partition is probably the only
owned the only way to deal with that
situation there there very few people
who think that an Iraqi national unity
government would be possible at this
point but characteristic of foxes then I
don't think they're staying zero you're
not saying like Robert Gates take it off
the table now is that a sign that
they're just intellectual cowards or is
it a sign that they actually have a
degree of intellectual imagination and
can imagine that somehow it could be
pulled out of the fire even at this very
late stage that's a value judgment I'll
leave to the audience to pursue that a
little bit with the regionalist saying
partition might be how it comes out to
the way they spell that out with this
kind of specificity that foxes are often
good at with howevers that it occurs of
itself or is it something that needs to
be the result of actual policy by
heavy-handed players like us I think
they believe it is occurring by itself
right now in a particularly brutal way
in a significant parts of Baghdad have
been have been de facto partitioned and
that but there may be of the view that
the u.s. and Iraqi central government
forces should take a more active role in
speeding that process up the Kurds have
already essentially partitioned
themselves off and really that it's an
issue of Baghdad primarily they're
joining areas raises than the further
question do these regionalists again
with the heavy-handed players in the
game including us if this thing is
arising somewhat of its own is the
intelligent thing to sort of step out of
its way to ease it into existence with
minimum pain and bloodshed to pretend we
don't want it so they're proud when they
make it on their own or what what you
know one of the interesting things I
thought the after the u.s. went into
Iraq be the regionalists were I would
say 85 to 90 percent against it doing
this the people who had regional
expertise they had language and cultural
knowledge detailed knowledge of the area
were overwhelmingly against it I think
but once the once the US was in a very
few were in favor of it early withdrawal
and even now I don't I don't I don't see
a lot of support for foreign earlier I
don't see any optimism that the surge is
is going to work but IIIi don't see a
lot of it's it's as though the did yeah
well once you've gone down that path the
conceptual and ideological disagreements
washed out among them and there are if
there are a few who think the the
situation is so is so bad and that the
Iraqi central government is so bad that
you really do have to get out now and
that we're there's a sunk cost fallacy
that we're spending the lives and money
after we'd just to recoup prestige in
position but well thank you for going
through that exercise with us and this
is a reminder this is you know Paul this
is good the scholarship and academic
research in progress these are not
academic questions
and these are really fateful things that
the hedgehogs the foxes and us voters
and everybody else is in the thick of
sorting out in any forms of thinking
that are more predictive and are more
self-critical and are more adaptive
strike me as the way to go and we just
learned how to do it tonight thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]